mais d'abord un service après-vente 5
étoiles pour l'hôpital de tours 48
heures après l'intervention
présidentielle jean castex et olivier
ferrand était ce matin auprès des
soignants du chu
d'abord une confirmation huit lits
supplémentaires seront créés en
réanimation
un service asphyxié par le commis de 19
à retenir aussi une belle rallonge
financière pour le projet hôpital en
2026 les syndicats eux dénoncent une
opération d'enfumage sur place on
retrouve samuel colin c'est une courte
visite pour à un gros chèque
jean castex et olivier ferrand arrive
peu avant 9 heures dans l'enceinte du
chu
au programme visite du service de
réanimation occupé à 80% aujourd'hui par
des malades atteints du coc vide
il reste un seul lit disponible d'où
l'annoncé de la création de lui lit
supplémentaire en début de semaine
prochaine
alors évidemment comme à chaque visite
ministérielle gros dispositif de
sécurité
toutes les entrées sont contrôlés tous
les accès sont surveillés nous n'avons
jamais vu ça me confie un employé de la
direction toute l'organisation est
dirigée par le cabinet du premier
ministre
une intersyndicale souhaitent manifester
prêtes à manifester
elle est tenue à distance du cortège
ministériel et finalement accueilli par
un conseiller de jean castex
pour eux tout cela n'est qu'une vaste
opération de communication d effet
d'annonce quand on dit qu'on va créer
des lits de réanimation en fait c'est
sur le dos de d'autres services il faut
savoir qu'il n'ya pas que les qu'ovide
encore sur france là il ya aussi toutes
les autres pathologies il ya 50% des
programmations et aujourd'hui on est
obligé de privilégier le choix
finalement le tri n'est déjà fait la
visite s'est terminée à midi à l'hôtel
de ville après un passage par deux
centres de vaccination dont celui de
joué-lès-tours la grosse annonce du jour
ce sont donc ces 165 millions d'euros
pour le nouvel hôpital trousseau
pour le député chalumeau c'est le signe
de l'engagement de l'état pour le plus
grand hôpital de la région et son
premier employeur 165 millions d'euros
d'investissement pour le chru de tours
et une augmentation du nombre de lits de
plus 84 lits ce qui est absolument
énorme inédit exceptionnel massif de
manière à favoriser à la fois
l'organisation de soi et l'accès aux
soins videmment pour tous nos
concitoyens nouvel hôpital trousseau qui
devrait ouvrir à l'horizon 2
ils 26 je vous le rappelle l'état
s'était engagé il ya quatre ans à
hauteur de 75 millions d'euros
ce serait donc plus de deux fois cette
somme engagée aujourd'hui investi
aujourd'hui par l'état la direction le
premier plus d'informations à ce sujet
en début de semaine prochaine
enfin dernière information c'est à
propos des vaccins 1,3 million de doses
devraient être disponibles dans les
pharmacies à partir de lundi selon le
ministre de la santé